This video is brought to you by rake on air Barnes with a great sound at a
great price. Check them out. A buyer,
acorn.com forward slash biographics more on them in just a bit.
Debts.
On September the 16th,
2015 CNN hosted a Republican debate as part of the lead up to the
2016 us presidential election.
Despite the fact that he had been dead for more than 10 years,
Ronald Reagan was mentioned during this event, 63 times,
the candidates themselves stood behind podiums in the shadow of Ronald Reagan's.
One time presidential plane found September stage was a powerful metaphor.
Anyone who pays attention to American politics,
couldn't tell you that the legacy of Ronald Reagan casts a long shadow,
the Reagan presidency,
forced and indelible image of modern conservatism that will likely India
well into the 21st century.
But the story of Ronald Reagan is much more than some straight line from
Nobel birth to Republican iconography.
It's a labyrinth path of career decisions that moves Reagan through Hollywood,
the American Midwest, and eventually the white house,
even as political positions were non-linear he's often thought of as a
quintessential conservative, but the truth is Reagan was rarely predictable.
He rallied against big governments,
but he also loved the new deal campaigned against Richard Nixon and oversaw the
largest goober national tax increase in American history.
The 40th president spent a lifetime accumulating nicknames.
You can call them raw, hide the Gipper, the great communicator,
or even the jelly bean man. But on today's episode of biographics,
we'll just call him Ronald Reagan.
[Inaudible].
Lots of American presidents.
Ronald Wilson Reagan was not born into wealth or power.
He was born on February the fifth, 1911 in a small apartment in Tampico,
Illinois,
his mother Nell Clyde Wilson was a Scot and a devout Protestant.
His father Jack was an Irish alcoholic who worked as a traveling salesman during
Ron's teenage years. Ronald's also had an older brother,
Neil who was two and a half years. His elder as a young child,
the Reagans moved around a lot with Jack and such a steady work.
The family had stints in Chicago,
Galesburg and Monmouth before returning to Tampico.
After Ronald's eighth birthday,
they lived above the HC Pitney variety store with Jack working downstairs
in the store itself were all his family eventually settled in Dixon.
He developed a reputation as a bit of a variety man himself.
Ronald was naturally athletic and enjoyed playing football,
but he also enjoyed time on the stage in the 1920s,
excelling at sports and theater just meant you were a well-rounded young adults
nowadays,
such a combination is unlikely enough to prompt Disney movies that involve
singing and dancing.
Regardless young Reagan was known as a multitalented youth, even at a young age,
he was a naturally gifted communicator who enjoyed telling stories.
He also worked as a lifeguard on the rock river in LA Parkway.
He made more than 70 water rescues at Eureka college.
He continued his stage acting while also serving as captain of the swim team and
the football team.
He took an interest in campus politics to where his intelligence and gift of
gab. And in the position of student council presidents,
he graduated with a double major in sociology and economics after completing his
formal education. Reagan had to do that.
One thing that every Jack of all trades must eventually do
narrow his interests down to just one Korea. He shows sports,
taking a job as a radio announcer in Iowa in 1932. At first,
you worked for several stations,
but he eventually narrowed his focus to who radio in Des Moines,
offering play-by-play for Cubs games, especially reality.
It became maintaining a consistent play by play narrative over the radio.
Despite the fact that he was receiving any basic information about the game via
Telegraph,
why Reagan stayed in sports throughout much of the 1930s offering routine
comfort to Midwestern baseball fans throughout the great depression.
But in 1937,
he was traveling in California with the Cubs during the West coast swing and was
offered the chance to do a screen test. Reagan's still an ILT.
Tyler's had men took the offer and it led to a seven year contract with Warner
brothers. He appeared as the leading man in love is on the air. Later that year,
his career in sports was quickly vaporized by the potential of the silver
screen. Over the next two years, Reagan appears in nearly two dozen films,
including dark victory with Humphrey Bogart and Betty Davis.
He also made a dramedy called brother rats with Jane Wyman in 1938 about cadets
at the prestigious Virginia military Institute. Two years later,
Reagan and Wyman made a SQL called brother rat and the baby and the pair also
got married in 1940.
He returned to his love of sports to play George Gipp and a news rock biopic,
which gave him one of his more famous nicknames. The gypper an exhibition,
Paul anointed in the fifth, most popular young star of Hollywood in 1941.
The following year in 1942, Reagan received not his biggest role,
but perhaps his most important two years prior,
also Henry bellman had written a book called Kings row that focused on the
hypocrisy and his mythology life in the American Midwest.
And it became a best seller.
The book was adapted as a movie by Casey Robinson in 1942 with
Reagan playing the role of Drake here, Reagan's character, isn't the lead,
but he does I of a key scene where he wakes up from a medical operation and a
rogue surgeon has amputated both of his legs. Reagan forensically explains.
Whereas the rest of me and audiences eight at top Kings row is often considered
the highlight of Reagan's movie career Warner brothers tripled his salary to
$3,000 a week. You can do stairs on the precipice of true Hollywood fame.
Unfortunately Reagan's career was bound to be pushed in a completely different
direction instead of being called up to brothers studio for his next great table
read,
it was called to active duty military service on the 18th of April, 1942.
[Inaudible].
Back in 1937, when he was still covering the cobs,
Ronald Reagan had enlisted in the army reserves.
He was commissioned as a second Lieutenant in the officer's reserve Corps of the
cavalry, but was also classified as a limited service due to his poor eyesight.
When Reagan was called up to active duty, as I say,
it kept him stateside and off the true battlefields.
He was given a port liaison post in San Francisco almost immediately.
Reagan applied for a transfer from the cavalry unit to the army air force,
which he stayed in for the remainder of the war. Reagan.
The thespian was heavily utilized by motion picture units first in California,
and later in New York to create useful videos for the armed forces he was
involved in project seemed a training recruiting and even fundraising by the end
of the war, his units produced more than 400 videos for the air force,
including cockpit simulations for bombing runs of the Japanese mainlands.
He'd have to activity usually on December the ninth, 1945, having a teams,
the rank of captain after the war,
Reagan returns a Hollywood acting in a number of B-list war,
films and leaning ever so slightly into his dormant love for politics.
It became the third vice president of the screen actors Guild in 1946 while he
was making movies like stallion road and the voice of the turtle in 1947,
much of the Guild was forced to resign over a conflict of interest.
And Reagan was elected president of the Guild in a special election.
He was reelected six times,
including every year from 1947 to 1951,
Reagan led the screen actors Guild through a tumultuous time,
but his tenure is generally considered a huge success for Hollywood.
He helped secure residual pay for actors when their movies or television
episodes were rerun. He also oversaw a handful of labor management disputes.
This period of time was the beginning of the Hollywood blacklist era.
When motion picture company has kept a growing list of actors and actresses,
they considered to be communist sympathizers.
And with whom they would refuse to work,
Reagan was constantly asked how by identifying communists or to help clear the
name of someone who had been wrongly accused. For example,
there's a well-documented case of a young actress who barely had a foot in the
door in 1947, seeking help from Guild president Reagan's who play a good name,
both Reagan and his wife,
Jane Wyman cooperated with a number of FBI investigations regarding which
Hollywood personalities might be hiding or even not hiding communist sympathies.
He was given the code name T 10 and provided information to the U S government
on several occasions. Regular thought.
This was a good idea to a point like many Americans at the time,
he believed that communism and its beliefs were antithetical to American
democracy. However,
Reagan also showed some level of disbelief that the extent of the finger
pointing that the FBI was asking him to do at one point,
Reagan allegedly mouthed off to his FBI handlers asking,
do you expect to constitute ourselves as a little FBI of our own and
determine who is a colony and who isn't as the 1940s were coming to a close,
Ronald Reagan could feel his ambitions evolving again.
He was still acting in films and even began to consider adopting some television
roles, but the career he was envisioning wasn't quite so film focused.
His experience with the screen actors Guild had given him a taste for what a
real political career might feel like.
And he started giving serious thought to statewide political involvements in
California, Reagan's wife.
Jane was not nearly as enthusiastic about this potential career change.
Bottled his involvement with a professional Guild was one thing that she did not
want to be a politician's wife.
His new aspirations became a major marital conflict in the late 1940s.
There was another much more somber source of tension between the Reagans like
Jane had given birth to their first child, Maureen in 1941.
And the couple that adopted a son, Michael in 1945,
Jane was pregnant again in 1947,
but her second biological child was born four months early and died after one
day by 1948,
Jane Wyman had filed for divorce citing her husband's growing political
ambition, as well as his present day distractions with the screen actors Guild,
as the reasons for her dissatisfaction,
there were also explicit ideological differences.
Wyman was a Republican married to a democratic political activist.
That separation was finalized in 1949.
Reagan began campaigning for democratic candidate,
Harry Truman during his reelection campaign in 1948 for American history of
offs.
This was the infamous Dewey defeats Truman campaign where Truman had to win his
own election. After assuming the presidency following Franklin Roosevelt,
his death Jack Reagan had been a staunch populous Democrats imparting to his
son. The wisdom of trust, busting child, labor laws,
and minimum wage and progressive tax plans.
FDR had been an inspiration to Reagan throughout his entire adult.
It Truman was the obvious choice for Reagan.
He appeared on stage with Truman during an Los Angeles rally dispose of Rooney
as reporting from the Chicago daily Tribune. Reagan's man,
one big defeating Republican favorites,
Thomas Dewey with 303 electoral votes to 189.
Even while he continued to record films,
Reagan joins in on a number of democratic fights in the early 1950s.
He opposed Republican right to work legislation.
He also helped Helen Douglas in her Senate campaign against a California man by
the name of Richard Nixon, between his filmography,
his guilt presidency and his growing political portfolio.
Ronald Reagan had become the most powerful Democrat in Hollywood.
And just before we get into the rest, sure. Today's video.
I do want to tell you about today's sponsor Ray con.
Rayco made great earbuds with a great sound. There's an affordable price point.
They're all about innovative design, uh,
prices that just don't break the bank.
They sent me a pair of these the every day eat 25 earbuds.
And we'll just pop that in. And I've been using them for a couple of days.
They fit easily. The air,
the Bluetooth connects amazingly easily because now I'm listening to a YouTube
video. I was watching on my phone. Um, so I'm gonna take that out, but, uh,
it's pretty great how easily they do just connect just like that.
Plus they come with this case, which gives four charges.
So you get six hours in the air buds recharge it four more times in this case
now I've used cheaper buds have used expensive air buds,
but what Ray cones do is they deliver a premium experience at about half the
price of other premium wireless earbuds.
So if you just go to Biray con.com forward slash
biographics, you'll get 15% off your order and let's get back to today's video.
[Inaudible].
Reagan's priorities began to change pretty dramatically again in the 1950s,
but this time it wasn't his career aspirations that were evolving.
It was his idea and logical ones. For one thing,
Reagan began to feel comfortable with the idea of remarrying.
Reagan was emotionally wrecked after his divorce from Jane Wyman,
perhaps in part, because he felt like her complaints about him were true.
He had been consumed by his work with a screen actors Guild.
Since his divorce Reagan had met a woman and he felt a deep connection with,
but he wasn't prepared to retire the not just yet as for the women that are
court Reagan's attention or remember fearful Guild member who had comes a Reagan
for help when the FBI was looking to make her as communist. Well,
her name was Nancy Davis, a lesson,
no New York city transplants and small time Hollywood actress after Reagan's
divorce. He finally gave in and remarried on the 4th of March, 1952,
realizing that she was the true love of his life.
Nancy Davis retains her stage name for movie credits,
but legally she changed her name to Nancy Reagan, the couple of two children,
Patricia and Reagan,
who was born in October of 1952 and Robert Prescott Reagan,
who was born in 1958.
The far bigger diametric shift in Reagan's life was political in 1954
with middle-age setting in and his movie career dying down.
Reagan took a job as the host of general electric theater,
a CBS anthology series that featured television adaptations of popular novels,
short stories, movies, or plays Reagan earns
$125,000 a year along with an even wider level of fame.
The show topped out at number three in the Nielsen ratings in 1957,
as part of his contractual duties as show host,
Reagan was required to draw dozens of general electric plants all across the
country and talk with the workers.
Reagan could speak as many as 14 or 15 times a day,
once a GE public relations liaison that worked alongside Reagan remarks,
the general electric saturated him in middle America.
As burdensome as the tools likely were for a national star like Reagan.
They were also good practice. Reagan was always a gifted speaker,
but his 10,000 hours of speaking to average Americans polished as a rater re
skills to elite levels,
it would eventually be nicknamed the Greek communicator exposure to hundreds.
Factory work has also shifted his political ideology. Reagan still admired.
FDR still believed.
And many of the populist principles that have been passed down by his father,
but his time spent in factories and around factory workers began to
refocus his attention on the benefits of business and the potential dangers of
unchecked government growth.
His metamorphosis continued into the 1960s when he was ready to formally change
parties and jump headlong into politics.
GE forbade Reagan from getting too politically involved while the host of a
popular television program theory would inevitably alienate viewers Reagan
didn't disagree with that premise.
So he left the show in 1962 and registered as a Republican.
I didn't leave the democratic party.
Reagan famously said the party left me Reagan.
The Republican jumped into the deep end of the pool very quickly.
He opposed Medicare legislation fairing that such a broad entitlement program
was the first major domino to fall on the way to a socialist America.
He also opposed the food stamp program,
which was introduced around the same time and proposed a raised the minimum wage
Reagan's policy positions were principled, but unsexy,
he made a far bigger splash when he gave a high profile speech advocating for
presidential candidate Barry Goldwater in the run-up to the presidential
election of 1964.
His speech a time for choosing is a 27 minute master class in political speech,
making Reagan smoothly, weaves together, anecdotes, jokes,
and admonishments against big governments, whatever your political ideology.
It's tough to watch the speech and not come away impressed by Reagan's Polish
as neurotic.
If we lose freedom here, there's no place to escape to.
This is the last stand on it.
Reagan's candidate.
Barry Goldwater was trounced by Lyndon Johnson losing the electoral
college 486 to 52,
but Reagan himself got a massive popularity bump from his national speaking
engagement.
One writer from the Washington post called it the most successful national
political debut. Since William Jennings Bryan in 1964,
it was completely unprecedented to jump from life as a TV star,
straight into the political arena,
but that's exactly what Reagan had the cache to do. So in 1965,
he announced that he would run for governor of California.
Reagan was campaigning to replace Pat Brown,
a two-term incumbent who had most recently defeated Richard Dickson in 1962
Nixon. Wasn't a true carpetbagger as he was indeed from California,
but he was running on the heels of eight years as Dwight Eisenhower's vice
presidents. And he had little grasp of the state issues.
Reagan proved to be a much tougher challenge for Brown that Republican converted
campaigns on the promise to send the welfare bums back to work among other
matters.
Brown had become unpopular after he went back on a promise not to run for a
third term, then deepened his unpopularity problems during the election,
after he jokingly compared Reagan's who and other former actor,
John Wilkes booth,
the results was a landslide victory for Reagan who won nearly 58% of the vote.
Don't cry too hard for Pat Brown though.
He finished his political career with a one win one loss election record against
future Republican presidents. And well that's not bad.
Reagan was determined to balance the California state budget.
So he froze hiring for state jobs.
He also instituted the largest state tax increase in us history included in his
new tax plan. Well hikes on sales tax cigarettes, alcohol inheritance,
and anyone in the highest tax bracket of owners, even beyond the budget.
Reagan had a highly eventful two times in office as the governor of California,
after campaigning on the promise to clean up the mess of Berkeley,
meaning antiestablishment, student protests, CSUN,
thousands of patrolmen and national guard troops to the university of California
to quell an ongoing civil conflict.
The result was one student death and more than 100 injuries to officers and an
incident known as bloody Thursday.
Reagan also fought a battle over death penalty gallery with the state Supreme
court. He signed into law, the therapeutic abortion act,
which was crafted to help stop dangerous backroom abortions.
He approved it to the family law acts, which legalized no fault divorces.
When he left the California governors mentioned in 1972,
it turned his focus to the white house.
He had flirted with the nomination in 1968,
positioning himself to receive attention while still early on in his first term.
As governor eight years later,
he was ready to challenge a never actually elected president Gerald Ford in
the Republican primary,
the Republican party needed to be steadied after Nixon's Watergate fiasco in the
ensuing midterms, which had been understandably dominated by Democrats.
Reagan believed that he was the man for the job.
And he didn't mind challenging a sitting president Reagan did give 48
significant push announcing his candidacy a full year before the election.
In November of 1975,
neither man was able to obtain the necessary 1,130 votes needed to win the
nomination before the Republican convention feeling he needed a master stroke to
push him over the finish line,
Reagan sought to appeal to the more moderate wing of the party announcing the
liberal Republican Richard Schweiker as his running mate.
The move backfired very few moderates were actually swayed to Reagan signs,
but he did alienated some of his more conservative base, four to one,
his party's nomination than lost in the general elections. A Jimmy Carter,
four years later, though,
the nomination was Reagan's to lose Reagan returned to his successful California
strategy, attacking a swollen federal governments that he believed had overspent
overstimulated and over regulated Carter embroiled in a stagnant economy and an
ongoing hostage crisis in Iran was soundly beaten.
Reagan carried 44 States and won the electoral college 489
to 49. It was one of the largest U S electoral margins of victory ever,
which Reagan promptly surpassed in 1984 when he beat Walter Mondale
525 to 13.
Us history is filled with rich ironies, but few of them.
Richer than the dramatic conflict and climaxes of the actor turns president's
entire books have been written about the events and nuances of Reagan's
administration, which saw an incredible tornado of events from 1981 to 1989.
I couldn't begin to describe everything that happened across those eight years
in just one section of one video.
The reader's digest version though. Well, assassins gums, invasions.
The Olympics economy, drugs AIDS, armistice. See what I mean?
Ronald Reagan's presidency in the 1980s sounds like an overstuffed scripts that
he might've read for in the 1940s. So let's start with economics.
The U S economy improved so dramatically in the 1980s that supply-side economics
is often referred to as Reaganomics. When Reagan took office,
the economy was stagnant and inflation was at an all time high for a peacetime
us. His plan,
the long side off the Laffer and other advisors was to cut taxes across the
board in all tax brackets. For example, at that time,
the top tax bracket for high-end has required a 70% tax Reagan reduced the
obligation to 50% over a three-year period.
The U S economy boomed through the 1980s with growth hitting an annual rate of
7.9% over Reagan's eight years in office critics were quick to attribute the
growth to other factors beyond the tax cuts like FECA tax rate increases.
They also pointed out that the robust economic health had done nothing to
improve the federal deficit, which was exploding,
thanks to increase defense spending, but that defense spending was intentional.
Reagan knew years of space raises and nuclear one-upmanship at tanked Soviet
spreadsheets. By the 1980s, they were facing even more problems,
arms conflicts with the majora Dean in Afghanistan,
massive agricultural and manufacturing inefficiencies from its plan to economy.
And by 1985 plummeting oil prices,
Reagan intentionally plans to dramatically escalate us defense spending even
further to push the Soviet Psalms at the brink of economic peril.
His plan included an elaborate missile defense system that was literally called
star Wars. However, when he sends pliability in Soviet leader,
Mikhail Gorbachev, he adopted a more diplomatic approach,
Reagan and Gorbachev engineer negotiated nuclear disarmament after a series of
conversations, including a secret meeting in Iceland in October of 1986,
less than a year later in Berlin Reagan uttered his famous soundbite.
Mr. Gorbachev tear down this wall.
It directly led to the dismantling of the Soviet union. 29 months later,
Germans could freely pass through the border between the East and West States.
All that isn't to say that there were no failures or problems during the Reagan
presidency, 16 American soldiers died in 1983.
When the us invaded Grenada following a queue,
a bomb in the American barracks in Beirut killed 241 American servicemen during
the Lebanese civil war,
more than 59,000 people died of AIDS during the Reagan presidency,
which was completely unknown prior to his time in office and which he didn't
formally address until the final two years of his presidency,
his wife Nancy helped enact a well-meaning anti-drug campaign go, just say no,
which was certainly well-meaning,
but it failed to recognize many of the chemical and physiological nuances behind
his drug addiction.
Still Reagan's eight years as president of the United States is typically hailed
as a meaningful, successful administration, even buying non-conservatives.
He set the American economy up for 25 years of fairly stable growth.
He nominated Sandra Day O'Connor as the first ever female justice for the U S
Supreme court.
He successfully navigated as an air traffic controller strike that could have
crippled North American logistics and transportation. He used his simple,
clear style of communication to re-emphasize American values and foster a new
sense of American patriotism. And to think it was all almost derailed,
just two months into its short tenure. When on March the 30th, 1981,
a college dropouts and failed artists, John Hinckley Jr.
Attempted to assassinate Reagan while other U S assassins often had political
motivations.
And Kenny Jr had developed a pathological obsession with the actress,
Jodie foster, after watching the movie taxi driver,
and he saw the assassination of a us president as a brilliant plan to get her
attention. So after Reagan had addressed the AFL CIO conference in Washington,
DC Hinckley discharged a 22 caliber revolver at him and his retinue
injuring four people in the Optima press secretary James Brady was permanently
disabled. Hinkley was tried,
but ultimately found not guilty by reason of insanity.
He called the assassination attempt.
The greatest love offering in the history of the world.
His verdicts prompted a reformation on criminal insanity, please.
As for the 40th president Reagan made a full recovery after being struck by a
bullets ricocheted off the presidential limousine.
He later told his adopted son, Michael,
that he believed he had been sped by God to fulfill a higher purpose,
whether or not the Reagan presidency was directly sanctioned by God is an
answer. You don't have to find on another YouTube channel,
but it's hard to argue that the Reagan presidency wasn't immensely
consequential beyond a surging economy and the end of the cold war Reagan
refocused American conservatives after decades of rudderless partisan
challenges, he set the stage for 21st century American politics,
coalescing mainstream conservatism around supply side fiscal policies,
small government principles and individual responsibility.
Reagan didn't lead much of a life after his presidency. When he was elected,
he was already 69,
which was the oldest president had ever been upon his inauguration.
By the time he was succeeded by his vice president, George H w Bush in 1989,
he was nearing 80 by 1994.
He had announced that he was suffering from Alzheimer's disease.
From that he kept his circle close. As the disease progressed,
he was only able to recognize his wife and a few other close friends.
He died at home on June the fifth,
2004 at the age of 93 after his death,
his body lay in repose that both his presidential library and in the written
dura of the us Capitol building more than 200,000 people came to pay their
respects. First in California, then in Washington, DC.
And that's appears to be the enduring legacy of Ronald Reagan.
Now 15 years removed from the end of his life,
whether you agree or disagree with his policies and conservative outlooks,
he was a galvanizing force in American culture.
This brought thousands of people together.
He's the most influential American politician since FDR and has become
true North for millions of American conservatives.
It's an appropriate legacy for a complex man of many interests for a political
faction that often sings of the limitless potential of America.
It's fitting that modern day icon was a man who seemed to be just about
capable of anything. So I really hope you enjoyed that video. If you did,
please do smash that thumbs up button below, and don't forget to subscribe also.
Please do check it off. Fantastic sponsor rake on linked to them below.
And thank you for one.
[Inaudible].